[Music]
happy to see you hey stand
up grabbing not ever easier
okay because I don't have to wor now a
stret giv okay so end up you know
options
or SC that's no good okay very
negative it's important your mental
mental attitude okay the POS okay this
is
I lost a second because okay if I scare
my body freeze that mean I can stop okay
instead I think in attack I am
attacking I am
attacking big difference this
is this is
okay so I am simply moving for me to get
the position to
attack okay so please think positiv okay
so I aiming
to okay I need one more step to complete
my
C okay two step please okay
wa and
[Music]
finish I hope you
here you got stuck
[Music]
how you come up change
again
scar once again I am
not
rocking or whatever okay I
attacking I'm
attacking this is my
sword after I cut
hey I got three
times
one e
down
one not even one extra step
simultaneous
[Music]
I okay simp make one extra step
out think hey please
[Music]
hey thank you